and what we're going to do is we're
going to
a technique for mushy and audio cutter
i'm not going to do that you're going to
do that and who else is strong i know
matthew's strong oh you're what's wrong
are you going to hold me
is it so somebody that doesn't know each
other
um
hands by the side
all right advice is a different
technique
so hands will your side
okay now
the technique is
this
and you know the vest don't you well he
thinks he does
i want you holding strong
okay
so how would we ever get the fork theory
working here
so so these are the challenges that we
come up against
yeah
that's it good
all right
so
already puffing them up now what a lot
of peculiar what a lot of people do
is this they go like this and they just
you're going to let me do it all right
because i can't
a lot of people do this you watch the
youtube
this art comes up and they take a thank
you
it's all out there you don't believe me
so they come here
do that they lift it up maintain thank
you
there's no way
look how much he struggled and he done
it correct
okay
so
you can't lift you do it by turning so
it's a conversion look
of getting his body to escape his body
escaped
you didn't see his hand go over his i've
been watching his videos today and you
didn't see his hand go
separate
separate on its own way to a sankyo but
now i'm going to ask you to do a sample
so these are our contradictions that we
we find difficult okay
now is he off balance or could he dig in
there he could dig in if you didn't want
to hurt him
all right
so so the lightness once you start
getting involved in these techniques
becomes very difficult it's the ghosts
don't worry
it's good
the person who run the hall before he
was one of the helpers he was an
electrical whip wizard and all the
curtains start closing on their own at
certain times
so
it's just to show you really
hate that you cannot
do this unless you're physically strong
but you can go oh i've made myself a
hummel
but that's the bit i wanted
so that when you come out you don't have
to take that
a second bite of the technique
okay
here
this hand is no good so i to do that
because my shoulder but what i'm going
to do is i'm not going to come out
and now apply this angle
i've had a bad shoulder a couple years
now
here
it's uh it's something it's all there
and do you know what he's feeling
all right so i think you've all got
enough information there thank you for
coming